hello everyone it's time to pick the
winner of the giveaway of the official
feed HS clock the DG t 2010 and before
that I will show you a wonderful 20 move
a miniature played in visa lots in
Croatia the year is 2000 and it's played
between Grand Master and an affair Jets
and the boy and medic although never
searches wasn't the Grand Master in 2000
he won his Grandmaster title in 2007 but
that doesn't really matter as this game
is beautiful nonetheless so if F just is
white and the medic is black let's see
this game we have E for b6 the purse
defense d4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3 g6
so this is the main line we have f3 c6
Bishop to e3 b5 Queen to d2 and this is
a well the most standard setup for white
here will appoint one on f3 Bishop on e3
Queen on D - waiting for black the
castle and play Bishop to h6 and
exchange the dark square bishop but we
have Knight B to d7 and now g4 we have
nice to be 6 + g5 immediately and black
plays Knight to h5 and here we have b3
and not allowing black any Knight to c4
ideas we have V 5 as the black would
really enjoy exchanging quick Queens
here as a white - does control much more
space but white place the queenside
castle and we have a Knight to d7 and
here we have d5 and well probably
probably the best move for black here
would be to push c5 but this is a hard
move to decide to play instead he played
b4 and white captures the D captures on
c6 and we have B captors on c3 and this
does seem like it's winning a piece
since this be captures and c3 it comes
with a tempo on the Queen but the white
simply capture screen captures on c3 now
this night is still attacked on b7 and
we have night to b6 and well after c7
and Queen to d7 white plays a4 and there
really isn't isn't any square at all for
this black knight to jump - and what is
preparing a 5 so instead instead of
trying to save this night like decides
to give back the material and well this
does open up well the defense of the of
the White King so we have big captures
on a four and now it's very interesting
the candor black queen capture this pawn
on a four and let's see what happens if
this is played if Queen captures on a
fourth and a white would play rook to d5
and this comes well with a terrible
threat of Bishop to b5 winning the Queen
and if black would play pawn to a6 the
defend this White has this rook to a5
idea now attacking the Queen and only
square for the king queen is Queen to d7
and this allows the bishop to h3 and
there are no most no no more squares for
the white black Queen and well after
something like f5g captures on f6 and
queen to f7 white simply wins the game
with Queen to c6 check were forking the
rook and well this is crushing for white
so after this B captures an a4 black
didn't capture the pawn he played a6 not
allowing Bishop to b5 and now white
plays a brilliant move he plays Bishop
to h3 now attacking the Queen and now it
seems the black can capture this a4 pawn
so he does he plays Queen captures on a4
and now comes White's idea
he plays Queen captures on e5 with check
sacrificing the Queen and if Bishop to
e7
for example defending or Bishop to e6
defending not capturing the Queen then
simply Queen captures on h8 wins the
whole rook
so black lady captures on e4 honey 5 and
this allowed rook to d8 check King to a
7 and a beautiful finished Bishop to c5
with checkmate as this Bishop is slicing
this way this Bishop is slicing all the
way here and this pawn and g5 is
covering f6 this is one of my amazing
meeting picture so yeah a beautiful game
by Nana fetch it's and now on to the
giveaway let me just kill this layer no
not that one sorry this one so ok
this is the video where you had to write
any comment about Thailand and use
hashtag Thailand that was the rule of
the giveaway
so if you did something like this you
should be okay last time we picked a
person who didn't write hashtag Dahl so
that was very unfortunate and as last
time I will be using this YouTube random
comment picker so here we just enter our
YouTube URL so let's just enter it it's
already entered because I is this one
yeah it's this one
and here we just press go and it should
pick us a winner so let's go good luck
to everyone okay he's just checking the
comments and if anybody wrote hashtag
town more than once the all the other
comments will be excluded this website
will only use one comment from one user
and it has 768 unique comments so this
is good to go and it says start raffle
and pick random winner so let's start
okay let's go okay
user names are flying around and let's
see who the winner is and the winner is
Malvina zazen he wrote I don't normally
play like hashtag tile but when I do I
lose so everything is in order
it's a nice comment and also he wrote
hashtag tile so congratulations Malvinas
says then you are the winner of the this
giveaway of the dg2 2010 I hope you
enjoy your chess clock do be sure to
contact me either by YouTube or by
Facebook you will have to you know
confirm that you are indeed this person
and that is it that is it guys thank you
all for watching as usual you can check
to my previous videos here and yeah I
will see you soon until the next
giveaway